this thing is still not obvious how I
get there because like what is that like
where does that come from but I have
some clues I have some clues for
instance said one just go back to your
diagram then what's the argument of Zed
1 2 pi 9 it's gonna come through this
pair right what's the argument of Z 2
it's 4 PI o 9 so this is going to come
from this pair and lastly this last one
will turn out from this pair okay so how
do I get this let's do some work over
here on the backhand side for a second
clear off some space this is not gonna
form part of our main line of our
argument but we're going to get a result
just like I do with my cosines then I'm
going to use to get to the next line
okay what happens when you go is Ed take
away something
Zed take away its conjugates have a gun
so if I go
Zed take away some complex number any
complex number you like and then I go
let's take away let's multiply by its
conjugate as well in order to do some
work here I need to take advantage of
the fact that what makes a contributor
conjugate is something that can be best
expressed in rectangular form so I'm
going to write this as its any complex
number I like so I'm gonna call it X
plus iy what is it's going to go
Zed take away X minus iy you came with
that so so this is just me saying I'm a
is any comfortable you like let's just
see what happens I expect something will
happen because of all this simplifying
it's gonna happen in here okay now
what's the easiest way to do this hmm
top of a couple of thoughts I'm gonna do
it like this I see that this thing with
the brackets in different spots is
actually difference of squares can you
see it do you see it see I've got the
plus and then I thought the - there must
be some difference of squares so I'm
going to say I'm gonna pair up Z and X
instead of X and I why I've got Zed
minus X there and then I've got minus iy
you came back and then here I've got Z
minus X again plus iy very good double
meaning
okay difference of squares you ready a
minus B a plus B a squared take away cuz
difference B squared so far so good
let's expand this thing okay Z squared
huh that looks like it might be useful
to me okay minus 2z x plus x squared
what happens over here yeah you square
the I which is your negative 1 that
negative 1 clashes with this minus sign
here and you got this guy okay
now this looks fruitful because I've got
as n square I've got to take away to Zed
what happens after my takeaway 2-zip
what's here and what does that compare
to over there now what's here is the
real part of a complex number that's
what causes right that's the real part
hey look there it is right there
X is the real part of a complex number
do you see that okay now what happens on
the anti a that's a bit more weird you
get this I was expecting one but it is
one it is one right because let me
rewrite this properly now okay this is
because that's go ahead take away two Z
now what is X I had to go back to
rectangular form but it really is it's
the real part of whatever the complex
number you were dealing with loss and I
just called the Omega okay this is
results we did it's the square of the
modulus of Omega right cuz Lord Omega is
the square root of x square plus y
square Pythagoras remember that I don't
have any square root there that's why
it's squared
you came with that okay now hold on a
second I called the Omega here any
complex number line all the omegas I'm
actually
dealing with these six numbers there are
roots of unity aren't they they're all
writs of unity all the omegas I'm
actually interested in sir what's the
distance to all of these roots of unity
enter one because they're all on this
unit circle right one span of course is
just one one one happy with that does
that make sense so I'm going to use that
result and I'm literally just gonna
write down next right I'm just going to
convert it I'm gonna say is N squared
takeaway to Z times the real part logs
then one that's that's what happens here
when I multiplied you gets plus mod Z 1
squared ok that's that's just I'm
interpreting that for this case because
I've taken the conjugates off I've come
down okay and then I do it phys ed 2 and
then have to it phys ed 3 right here we
go then squid takeaway now it's worth
mentioning the reason why I write this
gross long part here is because this is
a sure question this is a show question
instrumentally based on what I've done
over there on the right-hand side
there's no like extra bits from here to
here ok but I want to sure that I know
in the costs you find that it comes from
it's the real part of that first root
that I found right and I know way cause
for pie line et cetera I know where the
one comes from it comes from this
modulus squared now I can just I'm not
gonna write down because it's just that
like that's what it is that's the that's
the result okay this has to be somewhere
this is not a quotable result like I
hope it's not a quotable resort cuz I
don't wanna memorize that comment right
but it doesn't take too long to know I
have to do something like this in order
to resolve these conjugates like factor
pairs okay um that's the only way I can
simplify and get out these quadratic
factors which is a bit strange and not
very common so therefore it's that's why
we
I would prefer to do this and then do
that and notice that it has to be one
because they're all roots of unity
that's what I would not I would
certainly not write one yeah okay
because this argument that I've just
made is for any conflict zone that you
like and if I don't have roots of unity
then that will not be one it'll be
something completely different
okay a bit extra writing but it's it's
therefore more versatile okay far out we
always are there at the end
he's project and here's what they want
us to do it's yeah it's pretty much like
I said is it be like the hardest hardest
complex numbers questions you can ask
okay at long last here we are
they want an answer for that
they want us know what that is equal to
how wonderfully gonna work out what that
is it
now here's what I do this is again I
look carefully at what they want and I
take a magnifying glass to what I've
already shown what I've already provided
okay where on earth are pairs of cosines
coming up and the answer is in the
question I just did right and look
carefully at this right if I had a death
wish and I wanted to expand out this guy
right if I did that do you see for
instance one of the terms I would get
would be just as in examine he's a turn
that guy times that guy times one do you
see that would be one of my pairs sorry
one of my terms
okay by the way just quickly terms a bit
go in trapeze
when you go three of these times three
of these you'd get nine turns and then
when you go times three again you would
get three terms for every one of those
nine you get 27 do not write 27 tones
okay
just write for the ones that matter okay
now remember I just said and this is a
critical step ironically it's actually a
that we've already done before just
hasn't looked as bad right when we said
look when I let some of these terms come
up I said just as any vehicle I said
here's that what if I multiply that one
by that one and they multiply that one
by one do you see that okay um you'd get
close to PI a 9-year cause for pi over
nine there it is
then I've got something there but hold
on I've got more than that hanging off
for the right don't I because I'm not
just multiplying the cosines
I must win whatever comes with the
cosines which happens to be a minus two
Z and a minus two Z okay so in fact
taking those three squiggly underline
terms what I would actually get when I
multiply all of those if I'm doing this
right is for Ted squared cos 2 pi 9
cause hope I'm not do you see that
okay now we made for a second right that
was just one of them there's one of them
if I were to do another one pick another
combination for me like actually pick me
another combination perfect okay there
you go another combination okay again
you get the two cosines you've won
remembering that cause 8 pi 9 we can
swap that out for a minus cos PI on 9
that's going to turn into which one -
it's gonna turn into this one right this
is quickly it's gonna turn to this guy
so therefore that's fine but again
there's a 4z squared hanging out the
front do you notice that
okay so every time that you want that
will give you these guys every single
one is going as s squared at the phone
do you notice that okay now hold on a
second hold a second
this is a result this is not just equal
to nothing this equal to something how
many said Squared's do I have I actually
have no Z squared so if you take every
single Z squared term that comes out
from here every see and that's
manageable that's not 27 terms it's
doable in fact I've written down right
probing if you take all the Z square
tones and your atom all up you should
get 0